[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue ravi de vous retrouver pour notre
premier rendez vous de la semaine avec
deux débatteurs brillant pour débattre
autour de deux sujets chauds d'actualité
bonsoir nicolas baverez vous êtes
essayiste avocat éditorialiste au figaro
j'aurais peut-être dû commencer par là
c'est important d'un point de vue sur
figaro live votre dernière chronique qui
est publié dans le figaro papier de ce
matin est bien sûr disponible sur le
site vous expliquer pourquoi il ne faut
pas désespérer de l'italie notamment en
raison enfin en particulier en raison du
comportement exemplaire de
nos voisins dans la gestion de
l'épidémie je rappelle que votre dernier
livre l'alertent démocratique a été
publié aux édition de l'observatoire
bonsoir alexandre de victoire vous êtes
responsable des pages esprits libres du
figaro magazine
les aussi en charge du figaro vox que
tous les internautes connaissent vous
êtes l'auteur entre autres c'est voir le
dernier livre de recomposition le
nouveau monde populiste publié aux
éditions du cerf je vous propose si vous
le voulez bien de commencer par débattre
de
du budget de la france et plus largement
de ces milliards de ces dizaines de
milliards d'euros consacrés aux plans de
relance
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
sans en expliquer ce matin à la sortie
du conseil des ministres
voilà quels sont les objectifs vous
voyez ce projet de loi de finances
incluant un plan de relance montre notre
détermination à sortir plus fort de
cette crise
nous savons que les moments sont
difficiles pour beaucoup de français
difficile pour beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
beaucoup d'inquiétude
on ne répond pas à l'inquiétude en
entretenant on répond à l'inquiétude
en protégeant en fixant un point de
sortie et ce point de sortie pour nous
c'est une économie plus compétitive plus
décarbonée
pour les principales en chiffres tout
cela se traduit par des records en
cascade un déficit public x 3 qui va
passer de 3 % à plus de 10% des dépenses
publiques qui augmentent et des recettes
qui se sont effondrés à cause de la
crise et donc forcément l'endettement
public va augmenter nous allons
atteindre un record absolu 117 5% du pib
ça veut dire qu'il faudrait travailler
pendant plus d'un an pour pouvoir
combler ce déficit
nicolas baverez ses envies vous poser
une question très personnelle vous êtes
père de famille est ce que ces chiffres
là vous inquiète
pour vos enfants est ce que vous vous
dites on va leur laisser une espèce de
bombes à retardement ou est ce que ça
voulait serein je crois que c'est
inquiétant mais pas seulement pour ces
chiffres qui effectivement donne le
vertige
mais quand on regarde la trajectoire de
l'économie française parce que
finalement la france était encore la
quatrième puissance économique du monde
en l'an 2000 comme elle l'était
d'ailleurs en 1900 et là elle est en
train de se déclasser à toute allure
et finalement quand on regarde avec le
recul il ya eu c'est la quatrième marche
à les reconnaître en train de descendre
c'est à dire que la première cassure ça
a été 80 quand on a fait une relance
justement keynésienne complètement à
contre-courant
ensuite il ya eu le moment chirac
pendant que l'allemagne faisait l'agenda
2010 nous on a fait les 35 heures et
puis on a mis beaucoup d'argent dans le
social et on a dégradé terriblement ne
trouve plus son jeu que j'ai lu il ya eu
les deux parce que le au moment où ce
revers faisait l'agenda 2010 jacques
chirac a demandé aussi à être exonérés
des critères de maastricht mais il a
utilisé la dette supplémentaire en fait
pour dilapider cet cet argent ensuite
c'est vrai que on a raté la sortie de la
crise 2
8 2009 et c'est intéressant la rate et
pourquoi pas ce qu entre nicolas sarkozy
et françois hollande il ya eu un double
choc fiscal terrible qui a cassé
complètement la reprise est maintenant
c'est la quatrième marche qu'on est en
train de descendre et celle là c'est
vraiment la marque du déclassement de la
france
donc qu'est ce qui est vital c'est
d'essayer de garder notre appareil de
production et de préserver la capacité
de produire et je revois que pour
rembourser la dette ou produire pour ne
pas faire peur à nos créanciers c'est ça
mais non mais c'est d'abord si vous
voulez produire pour se développer pour
avoir des emplois parce que les achats
qu'une de ces phases si vous voulez par
exemple après le moment de très grande
des raisons de 80 on a été obligé de
faire des plans de rigueur
on a perdu un million d'emplois on a
cassé des dizaines de milliers
d'entreprises ensuite il ya eu leur fort
même chose s'ils voulaient à chaque fois
et aujourd'hui on voit que les
entreprises françaises elles sont
extrêmement fragilisée donc voilà si
vous voulez cette inquiétude c'est pour
ça que c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment est vital parce que c'est la
dernière fois que la france peut
emprunter 20 à 30% de son pub pour
essayer de se reconstruire son économie
et moi j'ai un énorme doute pour deux
raisons d'une certaine manière le
pruneau le maire a raison de dire que
tout va se jouer sur la confiance mais
je pense que la confiance elle n'existe
sur aucun des deux grands points de la
politique on voit qu'elle n'existe
absolument pas sur la politique
sanitaire puisque maintenant il ya une
espèce de bronca des élus de la
population des milieux économiques pour
refuser pour refuser si grande a été
l'un l'incohérence des pouvoirs publics
depuis le mois de février et sur
l'économie si vous voulez le problème
c'est qu'on a un déluge de dépenses mais
qu'on n'a pas de vraie stratégie
derrière et que ces flots d'argent vont
arriver sans doute trop tard et sont
extrêmement et sont extrêmement dispersé
donc on a on peut avoir malheureusement
un un gros doute et on peut se demander
si on ne va pas rater faire faire une
relance ratée comme ça a été le cas en
75 comme ça a été le cas en 81
un comme ça a été le cas en 2008 2009
alexandre de vécu à ce que le fonds de
keynésianisme qui a un an vous ne vous
aura pas un peu plus optimiste on la
partage exactement le même constat que
nicolas baverez ce parce que si je les
bien suivi favorable effectivement à la
relance il pense qu'il faut une relance
qu'il faut produire produire et encore
produire dans ce pays et donc la
question surtout aujourd'hui c'est pas
celle des déficits maintenant toute la
question où va l'argent
et là je partage la même inquiétude que
nicolas baverez je crois depuis des
années est un petit jeu il ya une
certaine droite qui pensent qu'il faut
toujours dépenser moi qui a un compte à
régler avec la fonction publique avec le
programme de camps conseil national de
la résistance et c'est l'autre côté il
ya une gauche qui pense qu'il faut
toujours dépenser plus quitte à faire du
client tg pense que le problème est pas
là le problème et où va l'argent
encore une fois sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire si on compare avec
l'allemagne même budget consacré à la
santé sauf que les allemands ont 28
mille lits de réanimation quand on en a
cinq mille e.on 24 % de personnels
administratifs nous on en a 35 % ça
c'est neuf points de différence et ça
permet d'embaucher 100 mille soignants
donc la question
elle est peut-être là et peut-être que
si on avait eu six cent mille fois niant
que ce serait aux pas obligé de faire un
rôle encore un plan de relance aussi
massive puisque on aurait dépensé moins
2 milliards dans cette dans le
confinement et c'est donc je pense que
la question est là et je vais vous
répondre moi où va l'argent
il va d'une part enfoncé effectivement
j'ai déjà dit dans une espèce de
bureaucratie complètement folle ça fait
quand même 40 ans qu'on est dirigée par
bercy sont des technocrates qui nous
explique qu'il faut dégraisser les
mammouths et qui ne dégraisse pas leur
propre mammouth donc je pense qu'il faut
commencer par là plutôt que d'aller
puiser dans la police à l'hôpital et
c'est tout ce qui est bureaucratie
unitile qui non seulement est
inutilement plus a tendance à
désorganiser la fonction publique ça
c'est une chose
la deuxième chose là où il faut aller
chercher c'est la dépense sociale là je
pense au livre de charles prat et quand
je dis dépenses sociales je pense pas au
modèle social je pense pas qu'il faut
réduire la retraite des gens qui ont
travaillé pour lord et l'envié mais je
pense aux prestations sociales 787
milliards ces deux fois le budget de
l'état donc le problème c'est pas
simplement
fonction publique c'est toutes ces
prestations individuelles au qui soit à
la caf le rsa les allocations en tout
genre il ya trop il ya des gens qui les
touche et qui devrait pas les toucher il
ya aussi les gens qu'il ya deux
problèmes il ya un problème
d'universalisation de notre modèle ça
part d'un bon principe mais par exemple
je pense pas qu'on puisse soigner le
monde entier sinon il est évident que
notre système de sécurité sociale va
s'effondrer en plus il ya un problème de
fraude effectivement qui a été soulevée
par ce magistrat charles trappe dans un
livre le cartel des fraudes qui vient de
sortir ces 50 milliards d'euros
je pense qu'avec 50 milliards d'euros
par an on pourrait de fraude
on pourrait peut-être trouver de
l'argent pour pour avoir plus de lits
d'hôpitaux ce que ça encore ça va nous
coûter une fortune leur confinement dans
les trois mois qu'on a eu on me donne
les six mois qu'on a eu on aurait pu
mettre le paquet sur le pire l'hôpital
ça nous aurait coûté peut-être plus
quelques milliards je crois que ça va
nous conter et coûter beaucoup plus cher
dirt confiné toute la population nos
internautes réagissent vous connaissez
bien les différents canaux pour ça il ya
le figaro.fr sur lequel intervient
christian pour nous dire quand on voit
l'état du monde
il y a un an tout sera à reconstruire en
mieux bravo christian ça c'est un
langage positif en tout cas volontariste
avec respect toujours sur lefigaro.fr
considère que oui c'est vrai la france
est endettée mais il fallait prendre ces
décisions
et puis cette réaction de st cas sur
youtube
c'est un peu comme prendre un crédit
pour aller jouer à la roulette au casino
avec le co vide on peut difficilement se
projeter même sur six mois alors vous le
disiez nicolas baverez en fait cette
hausse de l'endettement
c'est une tendance lourde alors on l'a
vu pendant quinquennat nicolas sarkozy
mais on pouvait dire c'est normal il y
avait la crise de 2008 on le voit là
mais on voit que même sous françois
hollande la dette a continué à augmenter
pourtant on n'a pas eu de choc
économique majeur
il ya une thèse qui est celle de notre
confrère françois lenglet qui dit on est
obligé comme ça d'injecter de l'argent
dans la machine
en l'occurrence eux en s'endettant même
si c'est l'état qui s'endettent parce
que pendant que les riches deviennent de
plus en plus riches
les autres les classes moyennes les
français dans leur grande majorité ils
s'enrichissent plus les salaires
stagnent n'y a plus de croissance et
donc on est obligé dû nourrir la machine
artificiellement
c'est votre avis aussi c'est vrai qu'on
est dans un système qui est complètement
artificielle puisque toute cette monnaie
en fait est émise par les banques
centrales
donc c'est un système qui est totalement
circulaire et qui est fondée sur une
idée du pseudo argent gratuit qui en
réalité ne l'est pas en 1980 la dette de
la france c'était 20 % du pib avant le
coc vide on était à 99 % à la fin de
cette année on sera à 118 % 120%
et c'est là où j'ai un gros doute c'est
que je ne pense pas que ça va diminuer
parce que je pense que là le prenons le
maire est beaucoup trop optimiste
pourquoi parce que les trois moteurs de
notre économie sont [ __ ] aujourd'hui
la consommation on sait qu'on a 100
milliards d' épargne
le taux d'épargné passé à 20% et c'est
pas en fermant les restaurants les qui
va aller consommer dans le l'atmosphère
extrêmement anxiogène que le
gouvernement installe lui même qui va
aller et sortir de tout le monde reste
chez soi donc c'est pas comme ça qu'on
va faire partir la consommation côté
entreprises c'est d'abord la
consommation est fait mais
l'investissement est en train de
s'effondrer
et surtout ce qui est ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est que la demande les
commandes de l'étranger à la france aux
entreprises françaises sont en train de
disparaître parce que tout le monde est
inquiet à la faute sur la capacité des
entreprises françaises à délivrer donc
les moteurs de la croissance sont à
l'arrêt et ça ça veut dire quoi que
quand on nous explique qu'on va
retrouver l'an prochain le niveau de
production de fin 2019 c'est
complètement faux pour moi dans le
meilleur des cas on y sera en 2023 et
c'est loin d'être sûr pourquoi parce que
je rappelle que il nous reste est patent
de pôles d'excellence que ça et
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est touché de
plein fouet l'aéronautique l'automobile
le tourisme les loisirs la culture
donc ça ce sont des secteurs qui sont
qui étaient les pôles d'excellence
conseil s'était piqué me de ce point de
vue là elle est terrible pour un pays
comme le nôtre qui soit tu vous
connaissez bien la haute administration
vous êtes énarque vous êtes passé par la
cour des comptes ce frère de ma part à
votre avis quand bruno le maire dit ça
ira mieux l'année prochaine ils nous
montrent des courbes extraordinaire avec
un rebond de la croissance une baisse de
la dette
est ce que lui même et les
fonctionnaires de bercy easy croix ou
est ce qui nous enfume ben non c'est pas
que le il nous enfume c'est que de fait
si le ministre de l'économie et des
finances lui-même
j ai trop pessimiste ça devient auto
réalisateur il est obligé d'aimer à
linverse al'inverse il faudrait quand
même être réaliste et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya quand même
j'allais dire un discours raisonnable à
tenir
on peut pas être parce qu'on ne peut pas
faire en économie ce qu'on est en train
de faire sur le sanitaire sur le
sanitaire à force d'être trop noir on
est en train de bloquer tout le pays et
plus on est noir et moins on agit parce
que moi on fait ce qu'on devrait faire
c'est-à-dire tester tracé isolé donc on
trace pas on isole pas et on soigne pas
comme on l'a dit avec les donc il faut
pas être trop noir mais al'inverse il
faut pas être irréaliste et là l'idée
que la croissance de la france sera de
8% l'an prochain malheureusement
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas y croire
compte tenu de ce qui aujourd'hui est
malheureusement dans le système est
connue des alertes quand même sur sur
quelque chose avec justement on sent
qu'on se dirigeait vers confinement au
moins partiel et j'alerte sur ce que
vous venez de dire le massacre des
indépendants qu'on avait on a un pays
qui a fait le choix d'investir
massivement sur le tourisme et les
services de secteurs extrêmement
impactés par le coville est donc un pays
qui a désindustrialisé massivement donc
on savait déjà qu'on n'avait plus
d'industries ça va être très compliqué
de réindustrialiser on avait
effectivement des secteurs dans les
services dans le touriste qui
fonctionnaient les restaurateurs les
indépendants etc
je pense qu'on est en train de de les
tuer qui ne se relèverait pas d'un
deuxième confinement et ça aurait des
conséquences à mon avis sociales
terribles mais des aussi des
conséquences sur notre art de vivre et
puis ce serait enrichir à l'heure où on
parle de rocade et de relocalisation
ce serait enrichir à mon avis les
multinationales étrangères chinoises etc
deschênes qui vont pas manquer de
racheter tout pousse à rester
indépendants qui vont faire faillite
pendant cette crise donc je suis très
inquiet là dessus est effectivement là
non seulement il pourrait ne pas y avoir
de rebond mais on pourra voir une france
extrêmement affaibli qui sera
définitivement le pays décrit par
wahlberg dans la carte et le territoire
est qu'avec beaucoup de jaurès a aussi
des conséquences politiques en matière
de populisme c'est à dire que c'est un
nouveau coup terrible aux classes
moyennes et il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui vont perdre alors qu'ils n'y
sont pour rien une vie d'une vie de
travail et sa très franchement il ya une
très grande légèreté de l'état qui
explique qu'avec des aides on va jamais
c'est pas vrai du tout une fois qu'on a
perdu son fonds de commerce etc
même s'il ya quelques années c'est pas
ça qui va aider les gens à survivre et
il ya une responsabilité terrible sur la
faillite complète de la gestion
sanitaire de l'épidémie parce que c'est
quand même ça lauriers c'est un autre
sujet effectivement
je laisse le dernier mot si vous le
voulez bien à nos internautes
rome sur lefigaro.fr qui nous fait
remarquer que le budget en déficit
depuis quasiment 50 ans effectivement
c'était 73 je crois le dernier budget à
l'équilibré
cela a bien arrangé toute une génération
ajoute-t-il de vivre à crédit et de ne
pas imposer les réformes nécessaires
christian toujours sur lefigaro.fr qui
nous dit ne pouvant emprunter investir
des milliards jusqu'à la limite de la
bonne valeur de la monnaie effectivement
mais le danger c'est cette perte de
confiance
et puis archos guy qui vient documenter
le propos d'alexandre ii vecchio pour
nous dire que l'aide médicale d'état
c'est 3 milliards d'euros et les mineurs
isolés
un budget de 5 milliards d'euros voilà
pour les réactions de nos internautes en
passe si vous le voulez bien un autre
sujet l'émotion est encore vive
après l'attentât de vendredi dernier où
un jeune pakistanais a blessé grièvement
deux personnes c'était au pied des
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo
plus les jours passent et plus on
connaît le profil de ce jeune homme
prénommé hassan
il est donc arrivé du pakistan en 2018
en prétendant qu'il avait 16 ans alors
quand vous êtes un mineur isolé
vous avez droit à une aide une aide qui
est donné par les départements sauf que
le département en question s'est dit
c'est pas possible il a passé 16 ans il
est bien plus âgées que ça et donc à
demander à la justice en l'occurrence le
tribunal pour enfants de cergy-pontoise
de faire des tests osseux pour essayer
de trouver son âge réel et le tribunal a
refusé en disant non on ne le fait pas
le doute doit doit profiter
à l'accusé en l'occurrence à ce jeune
homme est ce que nous avons trop de
scrupules
alexandre ii vecchio est ce que nos
règles aux grands principes de l'état de
droit finalement font le jeu du
terrorisme dans ce cas là oui je pense
que c'est c'est évident on a un papier
demain dans les pages débats de
jean-luis théâtre chariot qui a
travaillé au conseil départemental et
qui explique que ça explose ses quarante
mille cas de mineurs isolés par an et ça
a c'est une filière très clairement pour
le papa pour le terroriste ça reste
minoritaire heureusement mais en tout
cas pour les migrations clandestines a
ajouté à ça que 80% des gens qui sont en
situation illégale ne sont pas
reconduits on a un vrai problème des
flux migratoires sur lequel vient ce
progrès fait un problème d'intégration
est faite est un problème de sécurité
ça me paraît évident maintenant que pour
élargir un peu le débat sur l'état de
droit
je pense que c'est le débat fondamental
de cdd des années un des débats
fondamentaux des années futures
la constitution française l'article 2
est très simple le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le peuple qui
exerce sa souveraineté par la voix de
ses représentants et par la voie du
référendum le général de gaulle disait
il ya quelques succès qu'une seule cour
suprême c'est le peuple
donc voilà les choses la définition de
la démocratie a été très clair c'est ce
n'était pas le gouvernement du peuple
sous le contrôle du gouvernement des
juges sous le contrôle de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et je
pense que dans les démocraties libérales
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut que la
volonté générale soit respecté mais il
faut la borne et qui est certaine limite
qui est certes un contre-pouvoir ses
classiques dans la démocratie libérale
même jeu le sentiment tout de même que
l'état de droit prend le pas sur la
volonté des peuples notamment sur la
question de l'immigration mais également
sur d'autres questions et qu'on a de
plus en plus une démocratie sans le
peuple et ça c'est vrai c'est peut-être
un point de désaccord avec nicolas
baverez reste qu'il a une vision plutôt
que villiers
il craint lui la dictature de la
majorité mais moi je crois qu'on est
plutôt le risque aujourd'hui c'est la
dictature des minorités et le
gouvernement des juges et donc la
démocratie sont le peuple plutôt que la
dictature de la majorité alors vous
évoquez tocqueville et effectivement il
disait que en cas de longue guerre
les démocraties sont en grand péril de
voir la liberté remise en cause et c'est
vrai que la guerre contre le terrorisme
sera une bière très longue parce que il
ya des formes multiples
intérieur extérieur et donc le
terrorisme mais en grand péril la
démocratie aussi parce qu'il prend une
île et said as torreilles et
malheureusement avec des formes de
succès d une guerre civile à l'intérieur
des d'aidé des nations libres alors là
où je crois que le procès sur l'état de
droit et est un faux procès c'est pour
deux raisons d'abord si on regarde juste
la france on constate que finalement
dans les dernières décennies la france a
été confrontée toute une série de chocs
il ya eu le krach de 2008 il ya eu les
attentats terroristes la vague de 2015
endémique depuis
et puis l épidémie se trouve que notre
pays est passé à chaque fois côté
dépassé à chaque fois côté d'ailleurs
pour la raison que vous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure c'est qu'on a un état qui
est énorme
impuissant à la fois le obèses et est
paralysé et je crois pas que ce soit le
l'état droit parce que là encore
regardez regardez bien les attentats en
quoi est ce que l'état de droit était
vraiment en cause dans les attentats de
charlie ou ou du bataclan il ya des
défaillances de la police il ya des
défaillances du système pénitentiaire
mais l'état de droit lui-même il n'était
pas en cause il n'est pas en cause
regardez l'attentât de la préfecture de
police il y avait tous les signaux
faibles c'est pas l'état de droit qui
est en cause c'est simplement que parce
que il était dans la préfecture de
police au coeur du système de
renseignement
personne n'a voulu voir la
radicalisation de
de monsieur donc mais laissez moi je
veux dire jusqu'au bout c'est à dire que
le ce sur quoi il faut réfléchir c'est
que c'est exactement comme ce qui se
passe sur l'épidémie la faille c'est que
alors effectivement la justice a
sûrement une part de responsabilité mais
on n'a pas de stratégie globale de lutte
contre le terrorisme parce que chacun
travaille dans son coin
les services de renseignement dans leur
coin les services de police dans leur
coin
la justice toute façon elle arrive en
malheureusement en queue de peloton une
fois que les tragédies sont eux sont
arrivés on n'a pas si vous voulez si et
quand même frappant on n'a pas de centre
de commandement pour gérer des crises cl
aujourd'hui on gère cette crise
sanitaire avec le conseil de défense
c'est complètement absurde c'est pas une
crise militaire c'est pas un ennemi
c'est pas un état qu'on a en face de
nous et donc on n'a pas les outils on
n'a pas les instruments et c'est la même
chose sur le terrorisme donc mettre en
cause l'état de droit ou la justice
je pense que on se trompe on se trompe
complètement et finalement par ailleurs
pour avoir souvent y compris critiquer
la justice
si on prend par exemple en matière
d'antiterrorisme c'est plutôt un des
points sur lesquels la justice française
fonctionne fonctionne plutôt bien
c'est d'ailleurs à mon avis le seul
parquet spécialisé qui soit vraiment
justifiées pour des raisons évidentes de
leur parler
administratif je pensais même pas de ces
même pas la question pénale qui est en
cause on pourrait revenir moi je pense
que la politique pénale et il aura
beaucoup à dire mais là on est vous
dites ça n'a pas joué sur les
différentes vagues d'attentats qu'on a
eue il ya plusieurs exemples g celui de
nice en tête où on avait déjà le cas
d'un immigré clandestin qui commettait
ses actes là et je pense que la réaction
des gens c'est même pas de se dire est
ce que c'est une l'islam pas de l'islam
vous savez le débat qu'on a à chaque
fois ci les radicaliser par égaliser
mais c'est qu'est ce qu'il faisait sur
le territoire et donc la radio c'est
donc là et pourquoi 80 % des candidats
ne sont pas la loi n'est pas appliquée
oui mais c'est le problème de l'état si
vous voulez la justice elle fonctionne
simplement c'est l'état qui est
incapable d'appliquer les décisions
arrêtées sera lente et quand même
beaucoup de chaleur et là dans le cas
précis je voulais la vue à partir du
monde sociale à l'enfance c'est quand
même pas des grandes et des faciès et
l'aide sociale à l'enfance qui avait
demandé aux juges de faire ce test
osseux ce qui est dans la loi le juge a
refusé par principe et par était au low
si ça pose quand même une question parce
que s'il est avéré que ce jeune homme
n'était pas mineur on aurait pu
l'expulser
alors même que oui de fait pratiquement
sans doha et marcel doret 2 fait d'avoir
changé le cas ça devrait pas changer
grand chose mais vous voyez est il
il faut quand même garder raison c'est à
dire que le qu'est ce que précisément
vise les terroristes il vise à faire
sauter l'état de droit dans les
démocraties parce que la démocratie est
évidemment c'est le vote populaire et il
est fondamental
mais c'est aussi l'état de droit c'est
aussi sont des principes différents
c'est aussi le fait pour la majorité de
ne pas opprimer la minorité et pour le
minorité d'accepter qu'une majorité on
voit que c'est en train d'exploser par
exemple aux états unis donc il faut
admettre qu'une démocratie c'est quelque
chose de plurielles et qu'il ya des
principes différents et donc l'état de
droit il n'y a pas il ne faut pas mettre
le gouvernement des juges c'est pas aux
juges de gouverner c'est ça c'est
certain mais à linverse le fait qu'ils
aient un pouvoir judiciaire indépendant
et qui a une justice qui puisse
s'exprimer
et que
les principes de la loi s'applique à
tous qu'ils soient gouvernants tout le
monde en convient même aimé courir cet
état doit quand même enflé ces dernières
années avec des juridictions qui
viennent s'ajouter à d'autres jeux
indications je parlais de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme là la
seule vraie inflation c'est l'inflation
de la norme et donc c'est pas les juges
qui écrivent les lois le conseil d'état
l'a lui-même dit on à une des lois
absurdes qui font maintenant des
centaines d'articles avec du verbiage il
n'y a pas de norme c'est du droit flou
et donc la vraie responsabilité qui
s'est pas les juges qui font la loi à
amos et le monde politique sur les
mineurs ils fassent de la communication
parce qu'ils nous ce qui nous oppose
pourquoi c'est en train d'exploser aux
états unis il ya effectivement la sphère
djorf l'oeil avec sans doute des excès
de la police américaine mais on voit
bien que la logique de l'extension à
l'infini les droits aux minorités de
considérer d'essentialiser finalement
les minorités en les quinze ans dans un
groupe pour leur donnant des droits
spécifiques etc
ça fait exploser la nation tout
simplement et donc qu'il faut quand même
un moment donné qui est qui et une
majorité parce qu'il ya le risque de
tyrannie de la majorité mais je crois
que il ya un des risques des sociétés
multiculturaliste qu'on connaît aux
états unis en europe qui est celui de la
tyrannie des minorités également nos
internautes sont assez partagées bien
sur ce sujet une petite minorité 53 %
considèrent que non l'état de droit ne
profite pas au terrorisme
neil qui n'a sur youtube nous dit
personnellement je pense qu'il faut
garder toutes ses règles
même s'il faudrait beaucoup plus
contrôlés et puis babineau qu'on ne
présente plus nous explique sur le
figaro.fr que les etats unis se sont
posé la même question après les
attentats du 11-septembre et malgré des
méthodes très ferme guantanamo
surveillance massive bien l'efficacité a
été relative
et puis cette conclusion deux peuples
aux folles sur youtube j'espère que ça
n'a rien contre vous géré alexandre
peuple aux phoques qui nous dit oui
l'état de droit profite aux terroristes
et ce sera toujours le cas parce que
personne ne peut lire dans les poitrines
où les cerveaux c'est le prix à payer
pour un état de droit
oui je suis légèrement majorité 1 53%
mais je me refuse à opprimer alex
surprend pas cher de collagène ouest
quelques minutes pour évoquer la mémoire
de notre ami denis tillinac écrivain
essayiste journaliste denis était un
homme de droite dans le plus beau sens
du terme
il nous a fait souvent plaisir de venir
à point de vue écoutez cette petite
intervention qui nous avait donné
c'était en janvier dernier il y avait
une polémique parce qu'il ya eu des
procès de fait parce qu'on appelle des
néoruraux contre des propriétaires de
coqs qui faisait trop de bruit ou de
vache qui sentait trop fort et l'homme
de la campagne qui était dénis tillinac
s'était insurgé de l'utiliser que vous
qui vivez en corrèze le parti de l'année
grande partie de la vie je vis à la
campagne à les cloches et le coq le
matin veille il ya le coincement de
grenouilles à la tombée de la nuit
allait les ebooks
la nuit c'est merveilleux et bon
évidemment il y avait un tas de fumier
bon ben alors pourquoi le dr et du bon
sens c'est vrai que la vie à la campagne
nous met en rapport avec des départs fin
des odeurs des sonorités que je trouve
merveilleuse et qui font partie de la
vie du collège l'existence aussi s'ils
ne sont pas s'ils ne sont pas contents
xb qu'ils aillent dans un chalet mon
bébé elle leur demande pas de venir mais
s'ils viennent ils acceptent de vivre la
campagne que la bât blesse à un souvenir
peut-être personnel avec des liquides
inac haut alors j'en ai j'en ai deux
j'en ai de très nombreux mais plutôt
qu'un souvenir personnel moi je le
trouve que le finalement d'abord c'est
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire parce qu'on
ne peut en dire que du on ne peut en
dire que du bien c'était une
personnalité extrêmement forte
tonitruante mais tellement généreuse et
ouverte et finalement je trouve que le
il a eu la chance d'avoir une mort qui
lui ressemble
il était donc un festival de deux
lectures l'iran vignes c'est un homme
qui en bourgogne a vu une alors frais
vécue par l'écriture puisqu'il il a
pratiquement été il a été journaliste il
a été écrivain il a été éditeur la table
ronde
ensuite comme vous l'avez rappelé il est
mort à la campagne a clos vougeot ce qui
est quand même donc extraordinaire parce
que le il avait cet amour de la france
de ses traditions de sa culture et des
tiroirs et clos vougeot c'est un symbole
merveilleux même si ça n'est pas en
corrèze c'est le seul reproche peut-être
qu'il aurait pu trouver à clos vougeot
et il était là pour signer son
dictionnaire amoureux de de gaulle et
c'est sa dernière passion qui était la
passion de la politique
et il est mort un an après jacques
chirac qui a été qui a été son grand ami
donc c'est vraiment quelques et quand on
regarde cette vie bon il comment sont
ils nés en 1947 il est donc mort ans en
2020 il a donc connu une partie très
idéologique la partie de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
ensuite un monde tout à fait différent
est ce que je trouve formidable c'est
qu'il a réussi à tracer une trajectoire
qui est vraiment original qui
n'appartient qu'à lui et c'est un homme
qui s'était j'allais dire qu'il s'était
vraiment trouvé
et il était parfaitement vrai donc moi
c'est ce que je retiendrai un homme qui
était vrai avec lui-même et avec les
autres est un homme qui adorait la
liberté et qui était près y compris à en
assumer ses contradictions et ses excès
voilà je signale à nos internautes que
une messe en l'honneur de deux mythes
hier une ti linak pardon aura lieu
vendredi prochain à 18h45 à saint
françois xavier dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris alexandre ii
vecchio oui la une était un bon vivant
s'il ya un souvenir parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui aimait bien la chair qui
aimeraient bien au bois est finalement
ilham éléments il fumait il est mort
d'avoir vécu et c'est une belle mort
trop tôt mais c'est une c'est une belle
mort il disait il répétait souvent que
tous les gens qu'il admirait était mort
et qu'il était peut-être né trop tard
que je me dis qu'il a lui lui qui aimait
tant l'imaginaire français qui
rejoignent par de l'imaginaire français
ce qu'ils aimaient cyrano les usa au
chateaubriand et puis moi je l'imaginé
bien ce que les trois mousquetaires et
je les imagine bien là en ce moment en
train de boire un verre de corona avec
jacques chirac et de nous regarder
goguenard nous débattre avec les masques
et fermé les bistrots et je me dis que
peut-être que finalement il est vraiment
parti au bon moment à flot avant que ça
devienne insupportable pour lui c'est un
d'été c'est un des traits
caractéristiques de denis c'était son
humour qui ne le quittait pas on a bien
vu dans l'extrait qu'on a vu il avait
toujours un grand sourire je vous lis si
vous le voulez bien quelques phrases
d'un de ses livres les plus personnels
qui est joliment titré du bonheur d'être
réac apologie de la liberté et il dit
que l'un des traits du réac c'est le
sens de l'humour
la meilleure armure contre les
dogmatismes la sériosité larroy d'heure
mécanique
l'humour c'est le sésame du sourire
toujours sourire d importants des
arrogants des fâcheux des sentencieux
passé sans aigreur de l'humour et
l'ironie pour signifier qu'on est dupe
d'aucune singeries d'aucune l'hiérarchie
d'aucune idéologie
c'était ça denis tillinac adieu denis
[Musique]